come here hank
[Music]
hi i'm sakura and this is hank hi
i'm anthony i'm emerald this is fridge
and grandpa cat this is our new baby
shark this is my son's my little baby
today we're gonna be trying out some cat
hacks tips and tricks that have been
circulating on tik tok and
uh see how he likes them so hack number
one we are turning an
old t-shirt into a kitty holder okay
demon baby
here we go you might hate this
how can we do this
[Music]
this old man loves to be bjorn so let's
see how this
[Music]
works
that's not bad
[Music]
that's a 5 out of 10 for some creativity
but uh
not all cats like that pack 2 this is my
video
dance toothbrush on a kitty cat reminds
me of their mom so
today here we have pink
[Music]
bamboo for composting
[Music]
my baby boy my baby son
oh yes
[Music]
no risk of getting scratched in this one
let's try it i ran out of tape so it
looks like
this okay crazy
what do you think no it's not food it's
not food
hey please
aren't you interested in the square
another flyby two out of ten doesn't
work at least not for my cat
maybe it will for you kitty kitty kitty
german always works apparently
[Music]
japanese not as much all right we're
trying german here
starting hard and smart
it's not working
wow it's really powerful
wow he doesn't even care this is awesome
we should do this more often yeah hank
can't really deal with
vacuum cleaners i think yeah this one's
not
i feel really bad happening that one
okay next video is don't pet the cat
challenge
uh essentially you pretend like you're
going to pet the cat
and then see how they react when you
don't actually go through with the pet
hi sweetheart
okay you know what he doesn't even care
hank staden baden-hardenbot
oh
turns out when you try to pet your cat
and then you don't actually pet him
they come and rub up on you how adorable
is that
okay in this next video um the cat has
to go
through an obstacle course that we make
let's try it all right it's obstacle
course time
come here hank
oh this is expert stuff fridge are you
watching this
it's like catherine zeta jones oh man
oh good girl charlotte good
girl fritz you do not deserve this no
6 out of 10 for this one um high effort
on my end and i don't feel like it's
doing much for him
okay for this next video um there's a
sound that you can make
that apparently annoys your cat
[Music]
okay so if you have a cat you have to
try this out so as you can see if i put
my hand he does not want to lick me okay
weird i know
but if you scratch right here and you
put your hand your cat will lick you
it's crazy i know but try it he's
[Music]
loud
[Music]
what spread right here
come on
okay get your catholic challenge sorry
it's a one out of ten
straight up didn't work okay so for this
next video you can get a really cute and
funny point of view shot if you shoot
from like
the bottom of a toilet paper roll and
like maybe put some food at the bottom
and turn your flash on he's looking at
[Music]
it
[Music]
thank you so much
[Music]
see point of view hack finally
10 out of 10 because it's so cute when
it works well it's been a big morning
we've just finished all the uh
challenges and hacks and we're just
witnessing the cutest thing
ever over here
so overall what did i think of these
tick tock hacks
i don't know they're okay i'm really
happy that we did the vacuum on grandpa
i think that's something we're actually
going to do going forward
he looks really nice he's very fluffy um
toothbrush one's a good go-to because it
really always calms my cat down
if you're a cat owner you should try
this and let me know in the comments
if these worked for you i love you
yes i do something about the boy i do
yes i do yes i do i love you
yes i do something about the boy i do
yes i do yes i do been going crazy
all lately something about the boy
crazy i need you more and more
i have to hug you i'll miss you
something about the boy
hug you i need you more and more you
make me go
e come together